hey 42 here for many people a history of
space exploration often feels like a
very American story a whilst a moon
landing is rightly placed as the shiny
gold medal the Russian cosmonaut program
was also incredibly successful and
achieved many firsts utter - often
overlooked Moscow we have a problem
these days space exploration is a much
more collaborative process and is often
controlled by private businesses rather
than governments although perhaps Elon
Musk is building an evil moon basin will
become our cosmic overlord so today
we're looking at some of the biggest
contributions that Russia made to
mankind's exploration of space the
founding father of rocketry and
Aeronautics was Konstantin Sikorsky a
partially deaf scientist who was
home-schooled and ended up living as a
recluse in a log cabin south of Moscow
he believed that life in space was the
future of mankind where we could live
forever and be free from all our worries
sort of like a floating Disneyland he's
seemingly thought about every aspect of
space shuttle from steering thrusters
and a multi-stage booster system to
airlocks and even the closed system of
biology that you would need to make
self-sustaining food systems in 1903 he
published exploration of outer space by
means of rocket devices and in it he
calculated that you would need a speed
of 8,000 meters per second in order to
hold a minimal Earth orbit he showed how
this could be achieved with a multistage
rocket fueled by liquid nitrogen and
liquid hydrogen using an earlier formula
he had created to show how the mass lost
through burning fuel affects her body's
acceleration he was the first person to
show that space travel was actually
possible rather than just a jules verne
fantasy I'm not sure the same thing will
happen with the whole Journey to the
Center of the Earth thing though Jules
it's bloody hot down there Sal Koski
inspired many others including the
German Hermann Oberth
and American Robert H Goddard who built
the first liquid-fueled rocket but
within Russia
Korolev was his greatest disciple and
went on to lead the Soviet space program
Korolev started out as an aircraft
designer but in 1938 he was arrested as
part of Stalin's Great Purge where
Stalin cleared out the Communist Party
of anyone who might oppose him by the
time Carlos appeal was awarded he had
already spent months in a Siberian gulag
starving to death down a mine he lost
many of his teeth thanks to scurvy and
just generally had a really great time
his death sentence was overturned and he
spent five years in a shaka which was
basically a prison for brain boxes so
that they could be punished by the
country but they could still benefit
from their expertise it's similar to how
many university professors feel today he
began work on rocket boosters because
apparently just escaping from prison
with a Lada wouldn't have been good
enough after World War two he worked on
trying to understand and improve the
German v2 missile design and eventually
in 1957 the r7 samyoga
successfully launched the world's first
true intercontinental ballistic missile
on the back of this success he persuaded
Khrushchev then leader of Russia to
allow him to launch a satellite and beat
the Americans to the punch in just a
month they cobbled together a metal
sphere with a transmitter a few
instruments and batteries and on the 4th
of October 1957 Sputnik became the
first-ever satellite launched on a
modified r7 rocket Sputnik is the
Russian for satellite but was previously
used to mean traveling companion Sputnik
to contain the dog Laker the first
animal in space who sadly died of heat
exhaustion in just hours Sputnik free
then launched bought its instruments
failed which was intended to map the Van
Allen radiation belts the West's
continue to obliviously label every
subsequent Russian satellite or space
station a Sputnik 4 5 6 etc even though
in Russia they had proper names for them
Belka and Strelka
were the first animals to successfully
return from space and you can actually
visit their little stuffed bodies in the
Memorial Museum of cosmonautics in
Moscow
and fifty dogs were used in the program
mainly mongrel mutts as they were more
resilient and predominantly female ones
as they were better behaved the final
test flag was in the Vostok free ka -
when a dog named vadhaka along with a
human sized dummy named Ivan Ivanovitch
returned from low Earth orbit Korolev
really wanted to follow Sal cough skis
big ambition and head straight for Mars
but the space race with the Americans
meant that politics decided what the aim
should be so the moon became the target
but the rate of achievement was
phenomenal as both sides pushed to
achieve a series of firsts there was
barely any testing and deadlines were
suddenly dragged forward as news from
the other side came in Luna 2 was the
first space probe to land on Mars after
they missed by 6,000 kilometers with
Luna 1 everyone needs a warm-up shot I
guess Luna 3 gave us the first shots of
the far side of the Moon but it was 14
years before Pink Floyd released a
soundtrack so they were a bit too early
and then on the 12th of April 1961 the
big one the first human to leave the
planet Yuri Gagarin the whole trip in
the Vostok one took just 108 minutes
including the time it took him to
parachute down from 7 kilometers up but
even for such a short trip Gagarin
stopped the bus on the way to the rocket
to take a quick preparator II leaked a
tradition which is now continued on
every Russian mission a Yuri Gagarin if
you will and the Russians send empty
bladders up into space on a pretty
regular basis from then up as they
crossed off many of her firsts such as
Alexei Leonov spacewalk and valentina
Tereshkova flying the female flag in
space beating the Americans Sally Ride
by almost 20 years interestingly Sally
is still the youngest American to leave
Earth at 32 book a Garin was just 27 and
Gherman t tuc was only 25 the first to
spend a day in space and what about the
future
well there were a range of orbiters and
Landers being sent up to the moon but
this seems to be just a bit of
war the exciting things in the pipeline
are various collaborations with NASA yep
that's right
Russia is collaborating with NASA the
Kremlin also put 1.5 million dollars
into planning a mission to Ganymede
Jupiter's largest moon of course we all
know the big secret that the Russian
space program have been hiding from us
that if you open up a Russian rocket you
find another slightly smaller rocket
hiding inside and then another smaller
rocket inside that it's a very clever
system thanks for the view so to go for
more 42 normally government combat
obesity with hopeless advertising
campaigns and even taxing junk food
butcher pan went the extra mile and
simply made it illegal to be fat do you
ever hear a noise not a bump in the
night per se but a whole